[Music]
[Music]
you can get into battlefield one's
latest DLC they shall not pass this week
if you on premium assuming you haven't
been tooling around the community test
environment already we went hands-on
with the expansion 48 hours in which we
murdered a lot of French dudes and a lot
of French pronunciation we're big
battlefield fans here in the office so
give us the old thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel if you like our coverage
let's get to it
as an old school battlefield player this
TLC has two larger vehicle focus maps
that I love and two infantry focus maps
if that's what you're into most of the
new guns are either slow firing tricky
to handle or not so good at closer
ranges meaning they're decent on Twitter
and rupture the big map but lacking in
the tighter verdun heights and forth the
who yeah nailed it whereas Americans
would say Fort Knox by the end of the
session a lot of us switch back to the
older better gun let's talk about how to
use the new ones though the assault
class gets over ear old 1918 rifles or
as Americans say it the river role it
plays like a bipod mounted LNG and seems
like a crossover gun for assault players
who like to act like the poor players
access' fired in verse to close range
and can excel at long range provided you
drop it and pop it
the bipod that is this type of gun is in
keeping with previous battlefield DLCs
that tend to diversify class guns with
influences from other classes this gun
can't go toe-to-toe a close-range with
higher rate of fire weapons such as the
automatic oh-seok at fire bipod mount
prophet the assault class also gets a
shotgun but after testing it we didn't
feel it was as good as the older 12g
automatic hunter the support class gets
the sure shot or as everybody in the
room was calling it the choke at which
sounds like a dirty word when people say
it out loud it is a very slow rate of
fire hard-hitting weapon with 20 rounds
I'd compare it in terms of feel to the
m60 in previous battlefields but with
way fewer bullets it's surprisingly good
from the hips but generally out classed
as an lmg by even the starting Lewis gun
and at long ranges firing one of these
up will almost certainly get you picked
off by estelle ultimately this guns best
asset is its fast reload
this time around the scout gets to the
labelled model 1886 but to be honest
sniper rifles in battlefield one are
some of the friendliest in any
battlefield game with high velocity and
minimal bullet drop so they all pretty
much shoot the same lineup headshot
profit the Lebel has a good magazine
size and fast cycle rates however it
does suffer from a long reload animation
which is guess for people who like to
play Scout clothes in it was
surprisingly effective when playing
capture the pigeon on Swizzle which has
a treehouse how cool is that I had a lot
of fun with the Scopes variant of this
weapon but for more sneaky Scouts don't
forget to use your binoculars in iron
sights Bobby turned off finally the
medic at the RSC 1917 if you're a
proficient DMR player the iron sight
version has mild recoil compared to
other dmrs making it easier to get on
target combine that with a two to three
shot kill at medium range and you have a
strong medic gun that's only held back
by slow rate of fire and six rounds per
magazine because of the slow rate of
fire however in tight maps like court to
who you want an n 1907 SL sweeper or
something automatic the maps of they
shall not pass are gorgeous and range
from a close-quarters sport to a fun
river crossing and two burned-out
hillside forest the close-quarter map
Fort to do was a pleasure to run around
on being able to detonate lock doors
with c4 makes up for all those times in
battlefield hardlines I had to manually
plant by pressing a button rather than
using the explosives I had to blow [ __ ]
up on these type maps battle sub 1 is
making strides in reducing grenade spam
with recent patches that can help out a
lot making you feel like you can
actually fight and not just die in a
hail of your name the new front lines
mode made good use of each map with a
mix of engagement ranges and vehicle
type fertilizes the mode where teams
capture conquest I'll flag in order in
either direction the team that pushes
the enemy team to their final base
engages a set of rush Telegraph's and
detonating those wins the match in other
words it's slow Russian two directions
we also spent some time in the newsstand
shamal assault tank which can go
toe-to-toe with other tanks and his most
notable for its lethal ability to launch
a bird and drop artillery all around it
when being overrun although to be fair
this would mostly only stop players with
c4 or limpet mines as most other players
will talk anti-tank grenades from the
distance capturing this on safe
operations mode on Swizzle is the
massive VL nine points you see good
playing operations on twists all with
something special with ways of attacking
tanks going up against huge artillery
pieces the 9.2 can shut down a tank rush
right quick but is extremely vulnerable
to Scouts or any tank with a direct line
of sight there aren't a lot of them on
the map so you will have to fight other
players to get on one
other things there isn't much talk about
with the behemoth it's a big slow tank
that can to shot any other tank and
never has to endure a long reload cycle
its biggest weakness is that it moved so
slowly that it can't get between capture
points as fast as players and get around
it and capture them all so it can't get
away from swarms of enemy soldiers we
didn't spend any time with the trend
trader class but given how many times he
came at us you can take a lot around but
you can still be killed with a single
bayonet charge which is kind of dumb for
a melee focus to leave at the end of the
day I fell off battle sub 1 because I
didn't have enough content and I didn't
find weapon grinding to be very
satisfying they shall not pass is a
chance to go back and just enjoy
battlefield at its best when you can
just be whatever you need to be I
honestly wouldn't worry too much about
the new weapons just get on the new map
and focus on having combined arms fun
it's been a crazy month of content so
join us in the near future for our
coverage of upcoming Triple A titles
including Mass Effect Andromeda check
out our review for growth's Recon
wildlands in the meantime thanks for
watching
Oh